في هذا التراب دفن عشرات من ضحايا المقبره
الجماعيه التي اكتشفت في بوتشا بعد انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من البلده اوائل الربيع
الماضي
معظمهم ارقام بلا اسماء
[موسيقى]
الناجون من اهالي بوتشا يروون قصصا عما
يصفونها بالجرائم التي وقعت خلال سيطره
القوات الروسيه على بلدتهم في الاسابيع
الاولى من الحرب كما يقولون قصص تم
توثيقها في صور داخل الكنيسه التي عثر في
محيطها على المقبره الجماعيه
هذه الصور في مخيم صيفي للاطفال جعل الروس
قبوا فيه مركزا للاستجواب عذبوا المدنيين
وقتلوا الناس في الشوارع كانهم في رحله
صيد في بوتشاق وتلا 450 مدنيا بينهم نساء
واطفال وفي باحه الكنيسه دفن وسته عشر
شخصا استخدم الناس عربات التسوق لنقل
الجثث من الشوارع وكثيرون دفنوا في بحات
البيوت والمدارس والروضات ولكل صوره قصه
ستبقى طروه من جيل الى جيل كانت تلك صورا
من العام الماضي اما اليوم فهكذا يبدو
محيط كنيسه بوتشا هنا كانت الحفر التي
وجدت فيها عشرات طول جثث قالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه انها تعود لمدنيين من اهالي
البلده ووصفات ما جرى بانه جريمه حرب
ارتكبها الروس هنا
احداث مماثله حصلت في مناطق اخرى فتوافدت
البعثات الحقوقيه الاوروبيه والدوليه من
بينها لجنه تحقيق امميه خلصت الى وجود ما
قالت انها ادله على ارتكاب جرائم حرب
وانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان في كل المنيكييف
وتشارنيجيف
وذكرت في تقريرها القصف الروسيه على مناطق
مدنيه وما وصفتها بالاعدامات وعمليات
التعذيب والعنف الجنسي منها ضد الاطفال
والمسنين
بعد انتهاء العمليات القتاليه في المنطقه
كانت المهمه الاولى توثيق الجرائم التي
ارتكبتها وثق المحققون كل شيء اغلبيه
القتلى كانوا مقيد الايدي النائب العام
الاوكراني اعلن استكمال جمع المعلومات
وقدمت لمحكمه جرائم الحرب
وبينما تنفي روسيا الاتهامات بارتكابها
هذه الجرائم تقود السلطات الاوكرانيه مع
حلفائها حمله لانشاء محكمه خاصه لمحاسبه
المسؤولين الروس عن مقتل الاف المدنيين
كما تقول بينهم من وجدت جثثهم داخل
سياراتهم كاترين حنه الجزيره اربن شمال
غربي كييف